[Applause]
what folks is good mom
[Applause]
Ryan Hawkes
is a professional soccer player he's
done Isis all you with her
I'll buy the call for a couple of days I
won't be reachable where are you going
now
Atlantis Lana I'm Ryan crying Hawks like
a memo or something I snuck a picture of
him he is perfection
girls I made him drinks but the tape we
all know none like Ryan don't go for
women like you
I'll listen to her no she's right stop
following me I'll get in trouble I
better leave me I have a dear
it's for you I have to tell you
something I'm still married
your identity card was never scammed
back him last night his guest ID card
was also never skinned baking last night
fraternizing with a guest
it's an irreversible breach of contact I
want you out of this ship if you want to
go to the World Cup you just lay low
engaged TMZ that they broke up that puts
you in breach of contract you understand
that
you wonder yours you have no idea what
I'm capable of in two months if you
still feel the same confinement in
Petersburg
[Music]
we are meant to be together I'm gonna
see you soon
you